good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can sleep
better rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and also as you
watch if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put it in quotes
so other people can be inspired as well
and when you write something down
yourself it's much more likely to stick
for you as well enjoy we've known for a
very long time only about 50 years of
real research that if you're not getting
enough sleep your cognitive abilities
throughout the day go down your
creativity goes down your stress goes up
your bad decision-making goes up and
your ability to handle conflict or life
challenges and be resilient and happy
and positive all goes to [ __ ] so what do
you do how do you get more sleep how do
you finally manage as part of your life
because look we all have a lot of
expectations a lot of demands on our
lives and so at some point we start
believing the hype out there that oh hey
you can get by on you know three four
hours of sleep don't worry about it just
sleep a little let's get up a little
earlier and we start telling ourselves
big lie that we can get away with less
sleep even though we have 50 years of
science saying we can't especially today
you know there's this popular myth that
oh you know you can take you know sleep
for two hours you know rest take a nap
for 30 minutes here and there or sleep
for four hours and nap and meditate
throughout the day to catch up and the
reality is we know that's not possible
for the vast majority of people we would
say Brendon the Navy SEALs can do it I'm
like yes but you're not a Navy SEAL and
they hate it and they call it hell week
when they do that ok most normal average
must perform must be awesome care about
your high performance
and have to be smart people throughout
the day really must sleep seven to eight
hours a night so if you're not getting
that on consistent basis what can you do
[Music]
so I'll give you my routine I'll give
you my nightly ritual but what I
recommend for everybody watching is to
create your own ritual I mean it's
almost like I give you a menu and you
need to experiment and see what is it
that does it for you for me it's like 30
minutes before I'm going to go to sleep
turning off all my devices and gently
escorting them out of the bedroom it's
Gordon enough very good morning horses
you put them in the little homes outside
the bedroom turning off the lights you
know the bright lights making it to just
have one nightstand light and one life
in the bathroom then having a really
really hot wonderful and bath really
want that yeah we have some salt which
are very relaxing and flickering candles
but if you guys don't like baths have a
shower all right okay John I've never
used it yeah you're gonna have a shower
and hot is better than coal oh yeah your
your basic you basically want to slow
down your brain and soothe your muscles
and everything is like firing you down
mmm I guess when you're gonna oscillate
and I always feel ready to play exactly
you feel exactly the hotter basics then
it's perfect
you're hotter yeah yeah the hotdogs go
to a hot dog I don't have a hot dog so
and with a bath and and then put on and
if you usually is naked you sleep naked
but if you wear PJs and nitrous or
whatever make sure that your white
clothes for bed I used to sleep in my
gym clothes and then your brain gets is
confusing messages you know your dreams
are always powering down so even if
you're a t-shirt make sure it's not a
t-shirt you wear to the gym and then in
bed I only read physical books I I don't
believe anything on-screen
and anybody who is reading the sleep
revolution in bed I will consider it a
personal victory if you actually fall
asleep three twenty to twenty pages a
knife fall asleep
whatever ten pages you get drowsy you
let the book drop you turn of the light
you're asleep
so that is incredibly important for
those so worth children you know that
that's how you put your child to bed you
don't just drop your child in bed you
read them you read - you're given a body
for the mini PJs you read to them you
kind of transition you know it's like
the good night moon is a good night for
everything which is really a demarcation
line between your day with all its
stresses however blessed our lives maybe
every day has stresses challenges and
difficult things and in completion
there's nobody who has any interesting
job or is a busy mom who finished the
day and says I did absolutely everything
voiceover and that was on my list I
should have done never so you need to
somehow tell your brain and your body
we did what we did right this day and
now the day has come to a close
and we need to fully cross the line who
need to cross that line be there on the
screen to give our work and yeah at the
same time
couldn't connect cut off my I just
really I wish I could sort of convey
that feeling that I absolutely totally
believe now to everybody watching
because I promise series if you do this
every aspect of your life will improve
if you have any lingering doubt if
you're not going to be as productive
just try it yeah because it's like
getting in the Tesla you're going
together your destination pasta right
rulers know that we're with the kind of
it
consuming less energy in that hour to 90
minutes prior to sleep dim the lights in
your house don't look at any screens
anymore that means no TV and no handheld
you're not twittering and facebooking
and doing all the other things on your
phone and I really mean no texting
either just stop in that last hour that
means if you want to read a book go
ahead read it read a book ya don't read
like magazines with dozens and dozens of
pictures to drive start dropping
dopamine in the back of your brain stem
just read one thing read one article or
one book or journal and plan your day
with no noise no TV I mean I know you
got you might have the kids and they
might be loud everything else but then
turn the TV out for yourself and you
like but Brendon I got a fall to sleep
the TV no you don't you just taught
yourself to trust me thousands and
thousands of years of human history
passed with no television they slept
just fine I'm sure if you ever gone
camping or been in the great outdoors
you're like wow I sleep amazing it's
because you're not watching television I
hope right now people they're in the
campgrounds Travis watch their iPads you
know it's like you got to turn it off
dim the lights no screams no sound you
know it's just chill the last hour and
allow you to kind of glide yourself into
bed calm cool you'll sleep like a champ
tip number three is cool it down
I sleep in as cold an environment as
possible I sleep with less blankets I
don't wear any clothes and I turn the
air-conditioning down to around 69 70
max and I generally will have a fan
blowing on me the cool in my environment
the better sleep I actually get research
has shown that this is an incredibly
powerful and effective way to enhance
yours when you're hot when you're
sweating when you're sleeping with all
those comfy cozy blankets right when
you're snuggling with your sweetie do it
but when you want solid sleep get rid of
it how to increase the quality of sleep
don't try to increase the quality of
sleep the ideal way to live is there is
no sleep in my
but that's not possible
right now still body has some inertia so
it slips minimum rest at the time it is
at ease if you keep this at ease then
sleep does not occur to the body unless
it comes to a certain point of
exhaustion so body is never ever asking
for sleep but it is definitely asking
for rest if you do not know how to sit
here in a restful manner it'll go to
rest like this if you can sit here
totally at ease it'll sit here for hours
without falling asleep otherwise this is
the only way it knows how to rest so do
not try to increase the quality of sleep
did no such thing
just learn to keep your body wistful and
at ease consciously if you sit here now
one simple thing you can do is you sit
down you come and sit down here just
move your attention from the top of your
head down to your throws and see if
everything is closed and be easy and
relaxed and at ease or just in all of
this just bring this to ease as much as
you can not everything is in your
conscious level as much as you can
consciously bring it to ease you will
see suddenly if you are the kind who'll
fall asleep at ten o'clock if you simply
one hour you sit here at ease you will
see your sleep will get postponed by
half now you won't feel sleepy attend
naturally you're awake so instead of
trying to increase the sleep quality
now you increase the quality of life if
you increase the quality of life when I
say increasing the quality of life
nothing in your life whatever you may be
doing from simple breathing to
complex activity that you do in your
life the quality of that will not
improve if you cannot do it with ease is
that so
only when you can do something with
total ease let's say you're riding a
bicycle if you rode in like this like
this you can't say you're enjoying your
cycling if you can write it with these
it's so much is that even if you take
off your hands if you go only straight
the way you want it to go you're at ease
because that you are at ease the quality
of your cycling has improved isn't it so
these two things are connected so if you
enhance the quality of your life
naturally slip quota will go down if
your quality of your life goes bad you
can't do anything with these then also
you cannot sleep but stressfully you
cannot sleep not because you're well
rested you cannot sleep you cannot sleep
because you're stressed out if you do
this you will not live long if you your
body does not get enough rest it will
die it will break something will go if
you are not at ease that means you are
in this ease getting there you are in
this is means you're in a certain state
of ill health but if we say your
deceased that means you're dead
so don't move and stay into the
direction of this is more into the
direction of ease if you become totally
is sleep quality sleep quota will come
down quality of sleep will be good
because quality of life is good last
thing we have to talk about is improving
your sleep environment and that'll bulbs
your bed itself the amount of light in
your room the sounds the odors the
temperature a lot of different factors
so we're going to briefly go through a
few of them here and while we do that
for each one ask yourself if you could
be making any improvements so first off
let's talk about your pillow a couple of
things about pillows number one you want
to replace yours every couple of years
both because it breaks down over time
and gets less supportive but also
because every night you're sleeping on
it you're kind of injecting that pillow
with lots of dirt and germs and body
odor and stuff that makes it gross which
can make it hard to fall asleep secondly
and this was news to me until just
recently there are different kinds of
pillows for different kinds of sleepers
for example I am a side sleeper in four
years I was just using like the most non
supportive awful pillows until I learned
that a side sleeper probably is going to
need a firmer pillow that has these
gussets on the side of it instead of
just the two pieces of fabric that are
stapled directly together and after
sleeping on this thing for about a week
now I can tell you it is a lot better
than the stuff I was using before when
it comes to the temperature in your room
cooler is better and according to the
National Sleep Foundation the optimal
temperature range for sleeping is
somewhere between 60 degrees Fahrenheit
and 67 degrees Fahrenheit the amount of
light in your room or should I say lack
of light plays a big role as well
because pitch darkness actually plays a
big role in melatonin secretion so if
you have a lot of ambient light coming
into your room from like a streetlight
outside your apartment you can think of
a blackout curtain which will basically
eliminate that light altogether actually
got one right there that I use for
filming also if you happen to fall
asleep with the TV on you should
probably try to break that habit because
well blue light now if you're one of
those people who thinks that the TV is
soothing and they just can't all asleep
without it there are some sound based
alternatives and actually silence really
isn't the optimal solution for all
people because silence is so often
inconsistent there's a bump tonight or
there's a voice in the other room or
there's somebody's snoring in the same
room as you so having some sound that
can block
those inconsistencies can really help
you fall asleep one option you can check
out is ambient noise generators which
can generate both white noise which is
basically just consistent noise it
sounds a little bit like an air
conditioner and ambient noises like rain
and thunder and for me my favorite one
is noisy because you can add as many as
you want you can change the volume of
each one and basically create the
perfect mix for you there's also lots of
music out there that's great for fallen
asleep - I've made a playlist of my own
and found several unspotted I and I'll
link to those down below but my favorite
way to fall asleep is with audiobooks
for me at least there is nothing better
to fall asleep to than spoken word and
in fact ever since I discovered
audiobooks back when I was probably 12
or 13 all the way up until I graduated
high school and got a roommate in
college I would fall asleep every single
night to either Ender's Game by Orson
Scott Card or The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy by Douglas Adams and as a
result I have huge swathes of both of
those books basically memorized for me
the most effective strategy that I found
for sleeping better is having a night
time routine I think we all have some
kind of daily routine in the morning
what you do when you first wake up but
we don't necessarily have a great night
time routine to help you unwind and so
it changes as my life changes but just
like when a child is getting ready for
bed you'll have them get into their
pajamas and brush their teeth maybe read
them a story in the line bed and they
fall asleep that kind of regular
nighttime routine at least for me starts
to signal that okay it's time to wind
down kind of stop thinking about YouTube
and entrepreneurs and all the stuff that
can easily keep me awake all night long
because I'm excited and so my nightly
routine looks like this usually around
10 o'clock now we'll me and my wife will
take Timo our puppy out for a walk
haha or walk and come back we take the
stairs up 13 flights so that we're you
know lost some energy then we'll get
ready for bed I'll make sure that all
the lights are dim in the condo so
there's nothing super bright and in our
face even going to the bathroom
only the shower light is on instead of
the main overhead light because the big
lights keep you awake in our bedroom
I'll just have the nightlight on instead
of the overhead lights for the same
reason I'll brush my teeth a flaw I'll
go to bed and usually I'll sit up for a
few minutes reading the book I've got a
book by my bedside
I'll read 10 to 20 pages of that book
put my sleeping mask on
and go to sleep and that regular routine
starting from 10 o'clock to usually were
in bed by 11:00 and I'm reading till
maybe 11:15 11 20 somewhere around there
and that's where I go to sleep that our
15 our 20 slowly unwinds my body slowly
unwinds whatever stress or excitement
what's happening that day it gives me a
chance to connect with my wife and just
as a signal that okay now it's time to
go to sleep and so I think for you
establishing a nighttime routine that's
more than just five minutes will really
help you in unwinding what was happening
during the day and set you up for a
great night's sleep
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Robert barrier
asked me to so there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in the next edition to
believe life please leave it down in the
comments below and we'll see what it can
do I'd also love to know which rule did
you like the best what did you learn the
most from watching this video what are
you going to take from it that you will
immediately apply somewhere in your life
or your business I'd love to learn and
please leave it down in the comments
below
finally I want to give a quick charter
to door ruta rita thank you so much
Darwin for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really means a
lot to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I'm the author of the sleep revolution
transforming your life one night at a
time I collapsed from sleep deprivation
and burnout nine years ago now and that
is what started me looking around and
think that I was not alone millions of
people are suffering from burnout and
that we've reached the point in our
culture of glamorizing sleep deprivation
and yet all the modern science made it
very clear that's what started me both
changing my own habits and introducing a
sleep section at the huffington post and
bringing to our leaders and of us as I'm
doing in the book all the latest science
around sleep cultures often believe the
wrong thing I mean in the fifties we
used to think that smoking was glamorous
and we had doctors advertising
cigarettes literally in white coats
saying I smoked menthols because they
refresh my throat actually that sleep
deprivation is the new smoking and we
lammer eyes it you know have men wearing
it like a badge of honor and women too
but men really see it as every religious
symbol and brag about how they only got
four or five hours sleep which only
works if you have a genetic mutation
sleep is not negotiable it's not
optional it is the foundation of a
healthy productive and happy life